salut aujourd'hui jean rendez vous avec
mon pote et picto de la chaîne et picto
il voulait que je mentalise donc c'est
ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui ça y
est chez avec epic tôt et en est partie
mec sociale bien sauf qu'il a pas dormi
et victor les yeux c'est tellement
facile moi je suis sur une espèce de
ségou et quand apple ça peut du coup un
gyropode segway c'est la main lui des
sur une roue moi je sais pas faire de
l'art où je l'essayé thaler jette
ridicule à apprendre valeur c'est ça qui
va être drôle en fait à la base je suis
censé le manta bizet et j'ai
l'impression qu'il m'a donnés rendez
vous ici pour me ridiculiser ce qui n'a
rien à voir avant de parler à ta caméra
tu vas voir en photo devant c'est ça
ça vous pouvez retrouver ça sur la
chaîne sculpture chelou ya trois abonnés
et picto c'est celui c'est quoi ça
attends attends on est face à un truc
j'espère au moins qu'on capte la tnt
avec c'est un routeur les premiers
routeurs
mais victoria une chaîne de hockey dédié
à l'électronique on peut dire fin
taschen c'est une chaîne dédiée à
l'électronique
ouais et qu il fait des conneries
électronique oui moi je forme ça m'a
cassé une côte
c'était tellement drôle mais je crois
que c'est la première vidéo que j'ai vu
de toit sont way allez aimer vraiment en
plus j'aime bien aller voir sa chaîne
c'est vraiment cool tu sais quoi on veut
monter une chaîne secondaire dédié à
l'art moderne à l'art contemporain
augros culture les mecs regardez c'est
un signe du christ cosmique sylvain du
riz dès qu'il voit si tu nous voir
dédicace à toute manière on va bien se
marrer quand moi je montrais son mari
tiens tu vois ça par exemple ça c'est
l'aileron ça parce que c'est l'aileron
qui est tombée on était garée là bon on
a eu un petit problème avec sylvain
refroidissement
et fabrice est un pote des pictos qui
nous a prêté le matos pour pour faire
cette balade est en fait cette balade
qui n'avait aucun sens dans la vidéo si
ce n'est que de le faire c'était cool
merci fabrice on parlait avec epic taux
de ce qu'on pourrait faire moi la base
j'avais prévu un petit truc d'influencé
et puis lui pensait que j'allais
mentaliser en mode déduction est en fait
en parlant ici il m'a reparlé des
techniques de mémoire genre sur les jeux
de cartes il a signé les réelles faire
dit que t'avais galéré à retenir des
jeux de cartes ou du tout c'était
hilarant team moins de cartes avec la
méthode que sans méthode du coup il est
en train de me mettre au défi les en
train de m'écrire
25 mo ou 30 moche et plus que je vais
devoir mémoriser
du coup on va essayer de faire ensemble
essayer de le faire avec moi comme ça à
la fin de la vidéo je vous expliquerai
comment le faire si vous n'avez pas tout
retenu par an 1 c'est un gyropode dis
donc je ne sais pas où tu as eu des
preuves se divise en deux et une table
d'accord 3 c'est un sablier en trois un
sablier en 90 l'ophone pourquoi
xylophone mec parce que c'est un mot qui
a l'air compliqué donc pas présentables
l'oréal et m 16 et lg oui je me suis dit
je vais tout petit et xylophone chez
nous c'est pas des trucs dont j'ai
l'habitude
non mais bizarre je cache et je récupère
je récupère la caméra j'ai caché la
liste j'espère que vous vous avez retenu
moi j'ai essayé de retenir tous les mots
et les chiffres associés à ces mots et
maintenant et picto tu dois me tester tu
me dis un numéro n'importe lequel et
j'essaie de retrouver le mot entre s est
facile entre snj roux qui n'a rien à
voir avec un gyropode 10 ans 10 et la
caméra sais c'est facile c'est le
vaisseau le vaisseau cosmique de la
vierge marie à 25 c les orbes qui vont
avec le vaisseau d'air
2 pourquoi pourquoi t'as pas voulu faire
la table qui était en deux temps préféré
18 avec la chaise aller en federer qui
me dit un mot je te retrouve le numéro
stew livre aa [ __ ] pas mal j'avais pu
oublier celui-là il est en neuf et le
troll est bas alors lui il va me falloir
du temps trop laid pour le retrouver
le troll et le troll et de troller qui
me le dit pas je le retrouverai tu me
tues ne le dit pas j'étais en fait un
jeu tu me dis pair ou impair les 300 ou
décroissant croissance en 12 ans car
c'est le bio phone en 6 c'est le sable
si ça fait huit ans vite envie de trop
bien en design et en devenir mais
excepté au fil des ans qui permettraient
en 14 sélections 16 c'est le vaisseau en
18 c'est la chaise en 20 ans vainqueur
hommage aux plus grands ils vont bien
passé un cap et ses 122 ses lunettes en
24 c'est le drapeau et du coup j'ai de
faire les impairs décroissant en 1523
c'est les étagères dont 21 c les boîtes
on sait pas quoi mais c'est autant de
boîtes en dix neuf candidats en 17 c est
mon sang est important ce qui nous amène
à 15 ans car c'est le carton pour le
prochain opus 111 7 starter ça ne vous
fait pas si vous n'êtes pas celui qu'on
habille le secteur luxe et voilà c'est
bien ce qu'on aime c'est l'humour c'est
qu'on n'a pas non plus à des visions ça
nous fait passer aux trois ans ce n'est
pas non plus si vous saviez au 1 allée
oui je sais pas si vous avez réussi ou
pas vous pouvez leur faire en utilisant
des procédés mnémotechnique que
j'explique dans un des master class du
samedi qui s'appelle la table de rappel
je vous mets une petite fiche à cet
endroit là comme ça vous pouvez aussi
leur faire et comme sa victoire si on
fait des chèques parce que on est jeune
si cette vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
nous faire savoir en nous laissant un
petit fou sous son nez
il était calme plus en garde aujourd'hui
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo
vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale vlog charme